[Musique]
ce mercredi 13 décembre les élus du
conseil départemental se sont réunis
dans l'hémicycle du Palais de la source
pour la dernière séance plinièire de
l'année à l'ordre du jour l'examen et le
vote du budget primitif 2024 le budget
2024 a été adopté à la majorité il
s'élève à 1illard 327 millions d'euros
avec des dépenses sociales qui sont en
forte croissance plus de 33 millions
d'augmentation des dépenses sociales
c'est quand même conséquent je l'ai dit
nous travaillons en faveur des publics
les plus fragiles à travers un plan pour
les personnes âgés personnes porteuse de
handicap aussi un plan de protection de
l'enfance donc sur ces trois volets là
on avance après nous avançons aussi dans
d'autres domaines tels que
l'amélioration de l'habitat et là nous
sommes en train de travailler avec
l'État pour que la LBU puisse financer
l'amélioration de l'habitat aupr avec le
département et puis bien sûr il y a le
sujet B de l'éducation de l'agriculture
comme on vient de l'évoquer de
l'aménagement du territoire des routes
et de l'eau il n'y a pas de problème de
ressources il y a un problème
d'infrastructure nous avons investi
depuis 30 ans et on va continuer à le
faire pendant 10 ans de façon à mettre
la population réonnaise à l'abri des
difficultés en matière d'eau potable et
bien sûr d'eau agricole pour les
agriculteur au total ce budget primitif
2024 de plus de 1 Millard 327 millions
en progression de 5 % par rapport au
budget primitif 2023 traduit le fort
volontarisme et dynamisme de notre
collectivité en réponse aux besoins de
notre
[Musique]
territoire